The joe rogan experience.
It's like Joe said earlier,
it's,
you know,
for some people they can't handle this shit,
right?
Yeah.
It needs to be a driver's test for it.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
There should be a driver's test for pot.
That's a good call.
Everybody handles their shit.
Sit.
A driver's stands for pod is actually
very good.
Just get you really stoned and you have to listen to some like grateful dead and
then get you released stone and listened to some punk getting them and get
really stoned and mixes it with some alcohol.
You know,
there's like all these tests that you have to do and then you get graded on each
line.
Like,
okay,
you can get stoned with everyone except women.
You know,
you,
we put you with three women and you totally just started coming their hair and
then you started hitting him.
So
yeah,
yeah.
It should be some,
some evaluation,
but then it'd be by who the government,
the government's going to be able to step in and tell you what you just get,
like the boy scouts or something.
We should do.
At a campaign was to make the regulation,
the Internet,
you should have to write a blog and the internet could decide whether or not
you're a Douche,
you know,
just tell us about yourself.
Tell us about yourself.
Well,
you know,
I'm fucking pretty awesome,
but actually I'm the best at everything I do like totally fucking,
oh yeah,
you can't get weed.
You can't handle this shit.
Eat a few yoga classes for our son.
No,
I've,
I've seen people totally freak out.
There was one time that when like when,
when the Kush first came around in 1995 right?
I was one of the first people with it here in Cali and the Kush is just the,
oh,
super strong Oji Kush is obviously one of the strongest deep Endeca,
deep indigo to me it's the strongest I've smoked out of the shit that was
strong.
But that one after smoking it for like maybe since 95 til now,
it's still gets me high as fuck.
Okay.
No,
I can't say that for any other herb.
I get smoke shit,
loads of herbs all day.
But when we first got that,
so like we were the only ones with it at the time,
you know,
it was like a small circle of guys and,
and uh,
we were on tour,
went to Michigan,
right in Michigan,
had some good herb,
you know what I mean?
That's some nice green,
smelly shit.
And uh,
we were backstage chilling and uh,
one of my friends,
you know,
he had a group of girls that he knew out there and shit.
And um,
they come back,
hey,
so you're Cypress Hill,
Huh?
Where's all weed at?
I don't smoke note.
Don't smell no weed in here.
Yeah,
I heard you guys are the weed kings and all that.
And I'm like,
Oh shit,
here we go.
And a,
I bet you don't got no better weed than me.
We're like,
all right,
well we'll smoke some of our shit with you,
but look,
if,
if we smoke our shit,
all jokes aside,
just hit it slow.
Don't,
don't hit it hard because this shit is really strong and,
and I know you're talking all that shit,
but just,
you know,
just,
I just trust me,
don't hit this too hard.
Right.
She goes,
I probably smoked better weed than you.
Oh,
okay.
This was like in 1997 he always wants to pretend they have the best weed.
Why is that?
And they always want to brag to me that they do.
You know what I'm saying?
No one's ever like John,
my wheat is shit.
Oh Shit.
Weed man.
I got some whack.
Hi Dude,
I got some whack weed.
But you ever smoke by shit mark all day.
And I'm barely high.
But I only say that when I know the other person has better weed.
I don't want to go,
oh no.
Cause I want to smoke your weed.
You know?
So she says to you,
we absolutely better.
We probably,
I probably smoked better weed than you.
Right.
So I'm like more preposterous statement.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I've never seen a picture of you that a pot leaf next to you somewhere,
so she was openly testing me,
right.
So I said,
okay,
let's roll one up then.
Right?
So we wrote one up and just like I told her not to do,
she takes off fucking huge hit.
Like trying to show off.
So you know,
I know the super exaggerated on the,
let me prove how big of a stoner I am.
Hit right,
wrong move wrong.
Fuck it moved.
She starts coughing up blogs is shit head spinning and like within five to 10
minutes she was like,
what did you guys put it this week?
I've never felt this before.
What did you pick guys with this guy that she was laced?
I'd never smoked nothing like this had been smoking alone.
I'm like,
see,
I told you,
I said we hit the shit too.
I mean,
you don't see us freaking out.
You know,
there was nothing that you watched me roll it.
I told you not to hit it hard.
I said,
Yo,
you better take this bitch home.
You know what,
get your friend and take her home.
She can't handle her shit.
Oh,
have you ever felt that though at all?
Have you ever smoked something where you're like,
this shit was late.
This was like embalming fluid or
story like that.
But I didn't freak out like that.
It was,
we had just filmed this video for Latin lingo off of our first album and I
hadn't smoked all day.
My homie that lived in Long Beach,
you know,
he was like,
yeah,
come up bro.
We're fucking blazing right now.
You know?
And it was about 10 11 Clark,
whatever.
So I had all the way out to long beach and he hands me a bullet to circle a
guy's fucking room is just smoked out.
I'm like,
okay,
well fuck it though.
It's not going to take on to get high here.
So he gives me this three foot bong,
you know,
one of those graphics,
one's memory,
the old graphics acrylics with the,
like the tin bottom and shit.
So he gives me one of those.
I take a hit filling.
Cool.
Right?
It goes around the circle,
comes back to me,
boom.
I hit another one,
third comes back a third time.
So after the third time I'm like feeling extra high and I've like,
that's usually nothing to me.
I was like,
what the fuck?
Why am I feeling,
I'm like starting to feel closed in claustrophobic.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
I'm like fucking hot in here.
Could you open the window bro?
I'm fucking die.
Can't breathe.
Right.
And then I do.
Why are you freaking out?
I said,
I know man.
I'm high right now.
He goes,
oh,
it must be the Hash we put on the bottom on the ball.
Oh yeah,
exactly.
I didn't know there was hash on the bottom of the bowl,
but I was freaking out at first because I'm like,
man,
I've smoked this weed before.
Why am I so tripping off at three fucking bowls?
I had to leave.
I'm like,
all right guys,
I got to go and mess.
And ash is a very odd,
hi,
it's heavy.
That's heavy.
Yeah,
I definitely wasn't cause it's super cousin.
The marijuana.
Yeah.
Nobody went out of their way to tell me till after I took all three bowls,
you know,
like a champ,
cause I was a bong hit and motherfucker back then and uh,
man,
June dude,
after like 15 minutes I was just like,
man,
I'm feeling crispy is going on.
This usually is just a warmup.
Yeah.
I took a cookie once on a plane and it was a,
every now and then you'd get a cookie that just blows.
It blows your head.
Yeah.
And Mine and I took it before I got on board and so I figured I always time it
fucking an hour and 20 minutes.
That's usually what it takes right before you're just not moving wherever you
are is where you stay.
I got on board,
got in just in time,
but the plane takes off,
I strap in,
I pull back,
click,
click on the seat.
Right.
And just go into orbit.
Eyes closed.
I'm watching like neon cartoons,
fuck in front of my eyeballs,
literally seeing hallucinations and I'm feeling my body flying through the air
going for a hundred miles an hour.
I'm like super hyper aware that I'm in this metal tube hurling through the sky
back in my chair while this is going on.
I'm going,
fuck,
this is crazy and I'm hallucinating at the same time and seeing crazy things and
you'll you'll,
you'll take cookies and you'll be convinced it's over.
Oh yeah,
it does.
This is it.
Look,
I can't survive this.
The cookies are misleading.
The cookies are misleading because cute.
Yeah,
they taste so fucking good you like,
and then they don't hit you right away.
So you're like,
oh,
maybe I got an email.
And then before you know it,
you're like three in and fucking toasted beyond belief.
I know I've said this a hundred times in the podcast before,
but I just have to say it in the interest of that.
Somebody might not know this.
If you eat it,
it's a totally different with different high because your brain or your body
produces something called 11 hydroxy metabolite.
It's by,
by eating it,
it gets processed by your liver and it's like four to five times more
psychoactive than THC.
So that's the real issue with it.
And saying,
this is not,
no one educates anybody about this.
You just,
you just think it's,
oh,
this is strong.
It's not just strong.
Something you've never experienced before that if you do too much you'll freak
out.
Yeah.
It's a psychedelic.
Yeah,
it can.
for sure.
If you have enough of it for sure.
You could definitely have one of those freak outs where you're like,
I want it to end.
And the thing is you cannot make it in.
You got to ride it all the way.
The fuck out dude.
My friend Eddie Bravo had one where he was crying and thinking about his
grandmother and going through some crazy shit about this.
He had created some character,
like it was like a,
a a white guy who wanted to be a black rapper so bad he put black makeup on.
He was like literally putting black face on and he was saying that he had
vitiligo that it's,
you know,
he's just trying to even as skin out,
but,
and we buddied got so high for meeting this Brownie that he was so sorry that he
made it.
And he was like,
man,
people are gonna Misunderstand.
They're going to hate me.
They're going to think I'm making fun of black people.
What did I do?
Like he was terrified.
It was like he had gone to the grips of sanity.
Yeah.
And then in the morning,
you know,
he was fine.
He,
yeah,
he's totally,
yeah.
Back Down to Earth,
man.
That shit fucking paranoid.
Yeah.
When,
when you get super fucking highlight that off of,
you know,
an edible,
I mean,
you get you,
you know,
either you have a great time,
you know what I mean?
And,
and,
and you know,
you relish it.
It's like,
yes,
this was the fucking perfect,
perfect amount to have.
Or you're that guy like I,
you know,
like I said,
I wanted to add right now,
but you can't be half to ride it out.
And then you have to ride after,
ride it out and just always remember to breathe.
[inaudible]
you're a fucking human being.